your mom Ashley is a Creator in New York
City and former member of the content
house your mom's house who films every
single aspect of her life for better for
worse at that point for a while I was
like I'm never going to show my
relationships like ever again she's
daringly decided to post her most
vulnerable moments insecurities and
experiences for everybody to watch which
quickly garnered millions of fans and
turned into a full-time business that
now expands Way Beyond herself this is
her Story Journey as an entrepreneur and
motivation for business and success as
soon as you hit the like button and
subscribe it helps us out tremendously
thank you so much and now a quick word
from our sponsor now thank you Graham
for that beautiful introduction on our
guest Ashley now she films every single
moment of her life and you can probably
guess she uses a nice camera and
equipment and very expensive equipment
just like we do here on the iced coffee
hour but you don't need to if you want
to get started with our sponsor of
course stream yard how do you take
someone from being a casual viewer to
being like a hardcore fan streaming and
that's really really good yeah on Twitch
I did twitch during in covid for like
six months stream yard is a live
streaming software that allows you to
begin creating content with just the
click of a button all you need is a
camera and internet connection and
you're able to stream right now directly
from your browser by doing so you can
stream to multiple social media
platforms at the same time including
Facebook YouTube LinkedIn and more they
also offer various analytics tools such
as a tool that shows you which platform
is driving the most amount of traffic
which is extremely helpful to know it's
really the best way to begin creating
content without spending any money
because they offer a free package that
you could try out for no money it's free
all you guys got to do to start creating
high quality content for completely free
is clicking that link Down Below in the
description to join stream yard today
seriously it helps us out a ton here on
the iced coffee hour it would mean a lot
thank you so much stream yard and on to
the episode I love it down here I have
to say it's growing on me I was coming
down here at first time what is this
spot there are no windows down here
we're like nope I feel like we're two
floors below ground but it's really nice
yeah it's definitely fun yeah it's a fun
house you're telling me how much does
this rent for down here this room
specifically is uh 2 900. so 2900 no you
get no windows you get no windows in
here
it is the size of two New York City
Apartments so what's the but where's the
window you have no natural sunlight at
all that's the real estate agent in him
talking right now yeah oh my gosh what's
the full rinse on the house that's what
I'm wondering um the full rent is 16.5
16. flip between five people but
actually I would say that is very doable
for New York City wow so what is that
like three grand basically yeah
relatively yeah yeah some rooms probably
paying a little bit more and we have a
backyard everything so it's a Cool
Spring I think it's it's pretty I think
it's a good deal how is it living with
with so many people
um it's good I love all my roommates
they're all like super chill uh we all
travel a lot so like our schedule tools
are definitely like there's probably
like a few people home at a time but
it's really nice and it makes it more
homey in a way because I've lived alone
um a couple of times and it's it's nice
to come home and have the house be
Lively especially here like there's
always something going on
um but the house just feels like warm
and full so but the living alone uh
whole genre Now is really doing well
especially in New York my fam just I
feel like just pioneered that like
living alone in New York City yeah yeah
sometimes I'm like wish I could use that
title you could I feel like you could
just rent a studio for the purpose of
like living alone I know right that
would be interesting just a straight
business expense to be able to click
bait that yeah living alone in my studio
like or seriously I think just a video
title I moved out dot dot dot would do
so well even if you just get a studio
somewhere else like I feel like it's
reciting unnecessary drama like people
are gonna start questioning things I'm
curious is how do you think drama just
in general has affected your channel is
it generally a good thing or is it like
all attention is good attention or have
you seen negative effects of drama yeah
I mean I try to avoid drama at all costs
um so definitely like try to avoid it I
think it depends on like the type of
Creator you are I think there are
certain creators that like kind of
Thrive off of it they use it to grow
their Channel
um but for me I think at the end of the
day like my community is really the most
important so any drama that I can like
avoid is always going to be the best
even if drama brings you more views like
all of that I just I think it's better
to just have like a nice wholesome
Community like do your life do your
thing
um and not try to get into trouble just
for the views I guess yeah how did you
get started with YouTube
um so I started in college my freshman
year of college I was at RPI which is
Upstate it's ritzler Polytechnic
Institute so I was going there thinking
I'm going to do pre-med I will probably
go to medical school
and although I think I still would have
liked that route I was like I have this
creative side ideally I would like to
pursue this more so I decided hey I'm
going to do this on top of college
um I've always wanted to make videos I
used to make them when I was like 12 13
like I've had my YouTube channel since
then and like would post here and there
but never actually fully committed to it
until I was in college and then I did
that alongside my like biology degree
for three years until my uh junior year
of college when I finally decided like
I'm gonna probably do YouTube full time
afterwards and then I switched over to
business my last year and graduated with
a business degree really yeah which is
really funny but at any point did you
want to drop out and just like just go
100 YouTube for sure like my sophomore
year I would talk to my parents like I
need to drop out and they're like no you
gotta stick through this like they
really wanted me to have this kind of um
like fall back I guess just in case or
just like more traditionally I think
they just want me to like have my degree
just be like she graduated college yeah
um and I think I think I didn't like
necessarily need to go to college but I
really enjoyed College still and I think
it taught me a lot of discipline and
also I think
um from like a YouTube standpoint even
it was more exciting for me to like show
my classes and I would do videos where
like I wear certain outfits to school so
it gave me more things to do and I kind
of miss having that structure a little
bit now that I'm out of college actually
but what prompted you to first start
making videos like why did you start
first yeah so when I like first first
made videos I was probably like 12 13
and it was that era of YouTube where
Beauty gurus were like popping off I
don't know if you know Bethany Moda but
she was like one of them she was like
one of like the biggest Beauty gurus at
the time and I loved her videos and I
was like oh I just like want to do
something similar like I love to like
show like when I'm packing for a trip or
just things like that and I just really
looked up to her at the time so I feel
like that's what kind of got me into it
initially were your parents hesitant
about you like YouTube at like 12 13
years old 12 13. that's like sixth
seventh grade I know yeah that's why I
mean that's why I didn't ultimately like
continue it I think I made like 10
videos and then did your parents know
about that though they did and were they
okay with Steve posting videos online my
mom was kind of like like this is kind
of sketch like random like old men can
watch your videos like uh but
yeah mostly it just I don't know got in
the way of school I had my sports and
then I just kind of like fell off until
I later decided that I wanted to
um but even then initially my parents
were still like
hey shouldn't you be focusing on like
your classes and like your medical like
all of that stuff so
yeah but now they're very proud I think
they just didn't like understand like
initially like that YouTube could be a
job and I mean I low-key didn't even
know that either I was just doing it
because I thought it was fun
um but now they're like my biggest
supporters of it ever so what sort of
videos were you making in college in
college I made a lot of like hauls
actually I think that's what started my
channel and what that's what kind of
like brought people to my channel
because they were more searchable so I
would do like here's like a spring haul
or like a haul from like a specific
brand
um my first video that like ever popped
off was a Vans collection video actually
so I showed like all my shoes
um that's my first video to hit a
million views and I think that's like
what kind of like kick-started
everything what's the appeal to watching
a haul video because for me like I'm
thinking like if I'm perusing the
YouTube algorithm and I see something
like my spring haul I would like I don't
know if that's something I would really
like be super enticed I mean maybe it's
not the Target that I'm like
so what what is the appeal to something
like that because I'm sure you probably
consume that content yeah so I mean even
now I think there was a time in a place
where Halls were really popular I don't
think at the moment they're super
popular anymore
um but the reason why I think people
would watch them is because they would
be like Oh I'm gonna buy things from
like princess Polly for example like and
then you can go on a hall and see what
someone else bought off that website
that like looked good and you could see
it worn on a person and then you can
kind of go oh actually like I'm gonna
add that to my cart just shopping
purposes it's literally for just
shopping purposes pretty much but what I
did actually was I used to fill my hauls
with my siblings because I would watch
hauls and be like actually these are
really boring because like Loki like a
haul like is kind of boring and I was
like I want to like do hauls that are
fun that people also just watch like
just because they're a fun video so I
would do hauls that like had my siblings
in them and like were really like we
would just be like messing around like
it would be kind of like a vlog but like
centered around like occasionally like
showing pieces which is like a really
interesting setup but like that is how I
like started my channel though
originally and I haven't done that same
um structure in a long time but that's
like how I started how much did you make
from the video that did a million views
at that point I was not monetized so I
made nothing and when I actually started
YouTube they were kind of like updating
the partner program terms so I remember
I grinded YouTube for like a full year
like three videos a week and I never got
paid until I was like a year or more
into YouTube like probably over 100k
Subs really so you got a hundred
thousand Subs in your first year doing
YouTube
yeah what was the motivation to keep
going when you weren't making any money
from it and you were in college as well
so I'm assuming it was probably a pretty
like intense schedule yeah I literally
think it was just like something in me
was just like self-like disciplined to
be like you like told yourself you're
gonna do this like you better do it like
or I even I remember when I started in
college specifically like Emma
Chamberlain was popping off so she was
definitely like another
um like inspiration for me I was like oh
like I love her Vlogs like I feel like I
could do something similar I remember
like watching her videos and being like
I'm gonna start YouTube in the first
year I will get 300 000 subscribers and
like that didn't happen but like I came
a third of the way so yeah and I think
also like the community and comments and
having people kind of like uplift you
definitely like pushes you to keep
posting as well so how much were you
making at the time you graduated college
at the time I graduated college
I I mean I was making it enough to
decide hey I'm going to be full-time I
rented out my own apartment I'm like
trying to think of exactly how much I
made
um I would say as a Creator like the
amount you make is like pretty
exponential for the most part especially
like as you're initially growing
um but definitely six figures by the
time that I graduated college impressive
so there's no desire at all to like get
a job or take that did your parents
pressure you at that point to be like
well you could still just you know
pursue medicine no sometimes my mom will
still have a joke be like medical school
I'm like I'm good mom but um no at that
point they were like if what's working
is working and like keep doing what
you're doing although before we go into
that hold on one sec where's Jack yo
what's up Graham I'm so sorry I couldn't
make it again man I'm actually here in
New York trying to find funding for my
new genius business idea basically it's
like any other dating app except when my
profile shows up they have to swipe
right or else they get banned what do
you think pretty smart huh Jack that's
the dumb anyways dude even though this
is like clearly Fortune 500 level stuff
um I'm really struggling to find funding
Jack we've been through this you should
look instead to today's sponsor fund and
grow fund and grow is unique funding
alternative with far fewer restrictions
than traditional bank loans with their
12-month membership you could access up
to 250 000 of credit zero percent
interest all while retaining full equity
in your company and as a special offer
for our listeners fun and grow has
prepared a business funding master class
that uncovers the five steps to getting
up to 250 000 in business credit and
don't just take our word for it over 4
000 customers have given fund and grow
4.9 star reviews plus as an exclusive
bonus you'll get a 500 discount on their
services so don't wait to fund and grow
your business visit fund and grow Down
Below in the description to get started
today and now with that said let's get
to the podcast so then what'd you do
after college I lived in Troy which is
very Barren and boring actually I don't
know where Troy is yeah yeah
um I mean I like it because it's like
kind of my hometown but I live there by
myself for maybe like six months and
then
it was just like I mean I'm still in my
hometown so I'm kind of like I feel like
I really need a change of pace and then
after that six months I eventually moved
to New York afterwards when did you
notice your content really taking off
and why do you feel like people started
to subscribe to you I feel like my
content really started taking off
probably in 2019 so maybe like a year
and a half or two after I started like
initially posting
um I was doing a lot of college videos
which like unfortunately like right when
I was like oh my college videos are
doing so well was like covered and I was
like seriously but
um I think like what Drew people to the
videos were like probably a sense of
like relatability I was a college
student at the time so a lot of my
videos were kind of focused around that
um but also show my family a lot that's
also like a huge trait in my video so I
think that's also like something that
people kind of come to see because it's
like our little group our little family
and people get attached to everyone and
we just have like our jokes and our
moments and we share like I mean we
share like very intimate life moments
like low-key on my channel I feel like
so definitely that I was trying to like
build like an actual Community right
like fans rather than just casual
viewers okay how do you take someone
from being a casual viewer to being like
a hardcore fan yeah I think I actually
haven't done this in a while but I think
things like podcasts like this one right
now like are really helpful to kind of
like give people a more like in-depth
view of who you are or I also used to do
streaming and that's real like on Twitch
yeah on Twitch I did twitch during kobit
for like six months what was the
motivation behind me
um I just kind of wanted to try it also
I think I was like really burnt out of
editing so I was like streaming
um but it was also like a really cool
way to like be super present with your
um Community because like they're
literally like in chat and you like can
talk to them how long were you streaming
for like what was the date because of
time oh my gosh when I like was really
strange I would stream like five days a
week for like four hours a day what was
this what was the stream crazy sometimes
we'd be playing Among Us
like oh man that's the only game there
you go okay that's the game I know how
to play so once Among Us fell off I was
like goodbye that's it yeah that's all I
got but or I would do like just chatting
or like I would edit or like oh like
you'd actually be editing a video and
like casually talking yeah yeah
interesting to be really chill I've
noticed that definitely amongst twitch
streamers that they have like very
DieHard fan bases and it's hard for a
lot of people especially the people that
do like spectacle content on YouTube to
really connect with their audience
especially if it's more like scripted
out content so they can have a ton of
viewers and a ton of subscribers but not
very many fans but one thing I've
noticed about twitch specifically is
that twitch creators like I mean you go
on their Instagram and they're like
engagement Ratio or engagement rate is
like it's like 40 like they have like
300 000 followers on Instagram and
they're getting 100
000 likes
so it's really interesting yeah and you
notice that's a be really positive for
you in growing your your fan base yeah
yeah for sure I definitely like those
are things I kind of haven't done in a
minute but that I'm like I really want
to do that again in the future just
because it was like made me for one feel
closer to my community but also I think
just like made everyone feel like the
community was really there how do you be
on so much because I feel like at least
for me it's like a constant when when
the camera is recording there's always a
bit in the back of my mind where I'm
like I'm thinking of what I should be
saying and I know I have to be present
for the camera and I can't like you know
that was definitely the most straining
thing about streaming that made me kind
of realize this isn't something I can do
as often as I thought because it is like
kind of exhausting to be like aware like
for that long
um but honestly like if you're like
gaming like with other people like the
hours pass like you don't even notice
but once you are just sitting there by
yourself and like chatting to a screen
it is a little more noticeable yeah then
what was it like then to move into a
house with other YouTubers yeah I mean
it was so cool I
I like group
owners I guess you might say um so it
kind of felt like I finally have
co-workers I finally have people that
like really understand my lifestyle that
I can ask for advice and ask for
questions and like just all kind of grow
together and it's kind of like if
someone makes a mistake then like all of
us learn from it so it's just like the
amount that you learn is more
exponential and I feel like I can really
trust everyone's advice like we'll
always be like how does this thumbnail
look or like can you help me do this on
Photoshop and things like that so I
think it was like super super helpful
and also just like coming to New York in
general was definitely like
I don't know such like a big like
helpful move for me I felt because if I
didn't move I'd probably like still be
Upstate doing God knows what but yeah
what is it about New York that so many
people are drawn to because it seems
like there is something different here
that a lot of people like it and uh it's
it's so much different than anything
that I've really seen or experience yeah
I mean I think it's definitely just like
you come here and there's like a certain
energy of people grinding and working
hard which can sometimes be like a
little exhausting but I think like if
you have like the right personality that
kind of like meshes with it it's like
helps you kind of do the same thing
um but I really like the walkability
that's something that I really really
like about New York is how close
everything is and I think there's so
many opportunities and especially other
creators so just like the community here
I think as well it doesn't seem like
there's anything Leisure here have you
noticed that like there's very little
relaxation interesting I I'm now
thinking yeah I don't think I've seen
anything like there are parks and stuff
I don't know if people like really going
like chill in park school when I was
like everyone's like running people are
like hustling like yeah like a violin or
something yeah everyone's busy and has a
place to be La I feel like there's a bit
more of like a relaxed Carefree Vibe
Vegas is very much I think like yeah do
nothing like we're in yeah well it
depends where you go on the Strip
everyone's like on vacation so you're
not gonna get anyone really like working
except if they work there yeah then off
of the strip it's just quiet Suburban
areas in general I feel like it's kind
of hard to like feel like a ton of
pressure because there's not very much
noise it's not like there's like people
walking around cars honking everywhere
you know like pushing you so fast it is
yeah yeah interesting that's yeah it
took me a few days to figure out like
why you have this desire to like keep
working and going harder here and I
think it's just because everyone else is
like out and about again always someone
working and it makes you want to work
yeah I'm curious about the content
houses because
Graham and I have kind of realized
recently that we need to do a better job
at networking like we kind of generally
stay in our little bubble and we have
people in our bubble that we're very
close to but it's very rare that we
leave this bubble and like meet new
people which opens up new opportunities
and new doors um
feel like content houses
are a fantastic way just in general
yeah I mean I got a place in Vegas and I
moved in a bunch of people that are like
young entrepreneurs and I definitely
have found myself like benefiting from
being in a space with other people like
like-minded people yeah what has your
experience been with like being in a
Content house how has that positively or
negatively affected your just success in
general yeah and would you recommend it
to people that are trying to be good at
YouTube yeah I mean I think there are
tons of pros and cons I think as like a
YouTuber specifically it can be such an
isolating job that it's like amazing to
like find a group of people that have
the same job as you and that you can
like actually like I said feel like you
have co-workers but at the same time I
think pretty much every content house
that I have ever seen has like pretty
much failed or like has not like lasted
for very long or eventually like kind of
Fizzles out in a way and I feel like
there is always drama involved so I feel
like it's good if you're like
I feel like it's an experience that you
kind of have to be like do I want to
sign up for this
um and it's definitely good it's a
learning experience you get to meet new
people I think it definitely helps for
like growth for everyone in the group
um but with that being said everyone in
the group probably does not have like
the same ideas or and just butt heads or
whatever else happens so
is the high power still a thing is that
still going or no hype house is not a
thing anymore no I think they had a
whole like Netflix series about how it
kind of I can't joined that I thought it
was just the founder like some the
founder of something was not giving him
good deal a lot of the times the people
that found the the houses are not even
like the people in the house it's like
some random CEO of some companies that's
got a ton of money and gets like a bunch
of like 18 year old kids all to like
pile up in a house why are you laughing
oh it's just laughing at the idea though
like piling a bunch of 18 year old
people in a house and just seeing what
happens maybe not seeing what happens
there's probably some like business
Acumen and reason behind doing it yeah
it sounds like it goes against
everything you would learn in like a
business it does it does but yeah that
was yeah just get teenagers together
with a cell phone have them post exactly
monetize genius throwing some sponsors
yeah you're good to go yeah I think what
happened in the hype house was like they
had I feel like it's like a bang energy
they're like you need to post the bang
energy sponsors
just posted sponsorship and like no one
would film or like they're all just like
doing their own things I thought they
were just like was it was that the that
was the group Tick Tock right where
they're supposed to do like a group Tick
Tock for bang energy maybe I have no
idea
this was like this is the bang energy
thing yes bang energy broke the high
power pretty much so they wanted bang
energy in the background of like
everything so like you when you see like
the dance of the like I don't know but
like but they're doing like that like
like that like whatever
she's shaking it back yeah just to do
that it just didn't do it which part of
the reason why is like they're 18 they
have like not a lot of dislike listen
they're highly successful but yes but
when you put them together in a room and
they have to do a sponsorship like a
deadline it's very little discipline to
get that done
I don't know what bang energy was paying
but uh
anyway probably a bag we should get the
CEO bang energy on I hear here's he's a
character yeah he said I mean I would be
down that would be fun it would be a
very interesting episode yeah did you
guys ever do anything with bang energy
no
I want to know because I mean we've
talked a little bit about like where you
came from yeah how you've become
successful but what you do you do it
extremely well like I've noticed you
have a very dedicated following you have
obviously a very successful YouTube
channel I want to know what you would
describe are the most pivotal moments in
your career the decisions are
opportunities that were presented to you
that I would say made the the this these
most Stark changes in your career cool I
think well I mean definitely starting my
YouTube channel that's the first one
um I think actually like when I signed
my manager just because most YouTubers
have like management that helps them do
things signing a manager for me was so
incredibly helpful
um just to kind of have them like take
some of the workload off of me and like
negotiate things for me
um I feel like that really also made me
feel like hey like this is pretty legit
like this can be my job and I think from
there I took it a lot more seriously
once I had been signed
um I think another big decision for me
was switching to a business major
because then that kind of decision
really solidified for me that like hey
your job is going to be YouTube let's
switch to a business major so that maybe
some of what you learn in school can
actually help you after college but also
at my college it was like really stem
based so I ended up like doing mostly
data analytics like in Excel so I was
like did it really help like I don't
know yeah um but
um I think overall probably the biggest
thing for me was actually just moving to
New York like I I think it really opened
me up to more creators
um and is someone that had been mostly a
college YouTuber
um
I think I like I could have probably
just Fallen right off like right after
graduating college I mean like the same
month I graduated college I hit a
million subs and I kind of was like Hey
like I just did all the things I wanted
to do
what's next and then just kind of like
didn't have as much motivation for it
for like a few months or just felt kind
of lost
um I think moving to New York and
feeling the energy here and meeting new
people is like really what kind of like
kick-started me to like really continue
with my channel in the way that I am
interested so moving to New York was
actually like one of the most impactful
things and then what about getting a
manager like how do you find a manager
because I know a lot of managers can be
extremely exploitative towards their
clients just in general there's like
kind of a negative connotation with
talent management in general
um how do you find your manager what
exactly does management entail yeah so
my manager like
he just like pretty much emailed me was
like I'm from this talent agency do you
want to hop on a call and we can chat
about it
um so it's like very chill and you
basically like kind of do like a
three-month trial and then from there
you'll have like a rolling
like subscription but like you'll just
like research there's some sort of like
what management fee or something
um no not subscript I shouldn't have
said subscription but like the contract
just like continual like updates every
like however long
um but so how it kind of works is like
your manager will like field all your
emails and things like that
um
I'm trying to think what else or what
what did you ask another question yeah
like what is it like entailed to to have
a manager like how did that affect you
exactly yeah I think so once I had a
manager
um I mean he definitely like if I'm
working with Brands he actually knew
what rate I deserved and I was probably
like I would literally do a haul like
just for the free clothes
like I did hella hauls like give me the
free clothes and like I was like super
happy with that but I was definitely
like really undervaluing myself as a
Creator
um so my manager was kind of like hey
like these are your rates like we're
gonna make sure that you get good rates
um and since it's like a talent agency
he also kind of like
would just help out with like strategy
or like
um I guess like publicity like in a way
and making sure that like we're growing
and staying on top of things
um but also I think once I started
signing like more brand deals here and
there I definitely like had to make sure
that my Cadence of posting videos was
very consistent I didn't want to have
too many branded videos so I would
always make like
two or three non-branded videos for
every branded video that I did and I
think that also is what made me
consistent enough for like my YouTube
channel to grow so it's kind of
interesting to be like oh like taking a
sponsorship is like literally like would
keep me on track to like keep doing
YouTube but it really kind of like gave
me a schedule and like pushed me to just
be like gotta keep rolling gotta keep
doing all these things but yeah I think
it was my fam who was saying that uh
when she gets a sponsorship that she
likes it'll give her inspiration for the
idea for the video oh yeah so she's like
all right I got this brand what could I
do with that that'll make a really fun
video and then she builds it around that
which I think is really cool yeah I feel
like I definitely do the same thing
because I like to make sure that things
are like super well integrated and I'll
of course like only take a brand deal if
it's something that like I love so
usually I'm super excited about it and
then I'll be like hey like what can I do
to kind of like formulate a video around
this specifically
um like a video that I'm working on
actually right now was like with the
jewelry company and it's kind of like
near Valentine's Day so I'm like oh like
what can I do to like make a video and
like I didn't have this video idea until
I had been pitched this like brand deal
um but I was like oh okay like I'm gonna
get Kelly a necklace and like surprise
him like in the airport for Valentine's
Day and like all of this different stuff
so definitely like can sometimes make
for more fun videos which is really cool
yeah how do you decide what to post and
how vulnerable to be on camera
definitely hard
um
Loki's been like trial and error like
sometimes like I'll say things and if I
like just don't feel like good about it
later I'm like okay the next time I know
like hey like keep more things private
like set more boundaries
um but I would say for the most part I
am a pretty open book and there's not
much that I actually won't talk about
um I feel like I don't really actively
think about it too much I just I think I
just like know in my heart like hey I'm
gonna keep this private it's private but
most things are not private is there
anything you regret posting or being
more public about
looking back
I don't think so
I know like
um in the past like I had like another
like relationship and when that
relationship ended I was like oh my God
I had this bro in like a hell of videos
and like now now I have to like archive
them or something
um so definitely like I think in those
situations you can be like oh like I
regret doing that but I actually
don't like I don't
I like to be vulnerable and I kind of
realize like at that point for a while I
was like I'm never gonna show my
relationships like ever again
um and then actually just like
completely came back on my word I was
like Hey like I want to show my life
like I want to be vulnerable like and
whatever happens like I'll deal with the
consequences but like I want to show my
life and I don't want to like hide a big
part of my life either so did you ever
undelete those old videos with the x or
did you just keep them unlisted I think
of them are unlisted and I think some of
them are still up okay if I remember
after we broke up I was like you can
always go through the YouTube editor now
and just blur them out you could just
blur them out
yeah that would be funny or you try to
cut around it so what's your plan for
growth for your YouTube channel how are
you going to take it to the next level
what's your overall life YouTube channel
yeah what's your overall situation going
on right now I mean I feel like I kind
of take it day by day
um sometimes I try to like think about
it too much and I'm just like you get it
over your head or like you over analyze
it and I think it's better for me to
just be like I'm gonna keep making
videos that make me excited that I like
to do and not focus as much on like the
numbers as much or like let it get in my
head
um
but I definitely think
um I want to do more like idea based
videos going forward I do a lot of Vlogs
but I think what brings more new viewers
to my Channel or like kind of idea based
videos and by like idea based I just
mean
like not travel Vlogs or like not daily
Vlogs but maybe like I just did one
where I was like oh trying every matcha
in New York City and that's something
that like someone that doesn't know me
might click on is it really drinking now
I am drinking a matcha right now it's
just I love the video or is this like
just you just got a mantra it's got a
matcha okay yes but I actually I had not
gotten it from this place before and I
also didn't get in the video but it's
pretty good because it is the best that
would have me it's such a good choice if
you said trying every Pizza in New York
City and just like every second is a
bite dude
this one is pretty good bite bite bite
yeah but I love matcha I am working on
actually starting a matcha company oh
really yes what's the goal with that the
goal is I love matcha and I'm like what
better product could I do within this
um
but yeah I I've always kind of I mean
I'm like working on merch right now
which I think will like launch maybe
like every season
um so I'm excited about that as well but
like I'm really really excited about
doing matcha I realized like
if like in my videos I drink it like all
the time it's like really within my
branding and it's something that like I
genuinely enjoy and I think that would
be like super fun
um also I guess the goal is I also want
to diversify outside of YouTube as much
as I can so trying to do a little real
estate try to do a little real estate
not really real estate but I am
about to close on a house really yes
congratulations thank you where like
what here which is in New York which is
a little scary but I was like you know
what I like New York like what like a
apartment or yes it's an apartment
um I always I like to say house because
it makes me feel like I can justify how
expensive it is but it is literally just
like an apartment I love this place that
I have here now and maybe like
potentially like I could renew like the
lease here and like still live with
roommates but I really want to have
another space that has good lighting
because this place yes does not have
good lighting like at all and the place
that I am working on closing on has like
beautiful lighting so I'm like okay I
can spend like part of my time there
have another place that's like kind of
like my own personal home if I really
want to say living alone in New York
City I can do that yeah wow but yeah
just like another place has really nice
lighting and maybe my sister will come
live there with me as well that's cool
it seems like home renovation content is
starting to come back in style do you
have any plans of like fixing it up
those would make great videos like yes
who's the one guy Lone Fox Lone Fox wolf
I follow him on Instagram his designs
are incredible and he goes yeah he
bought this whole building in Los
Angeles like a 1920s building and he
turned it into something incredible uh
by doing something like that like a
kitchen remodel yeah I don't know about
remodeling my Co-op board as the
craziest fee for remodeling they're like
if you do your kitchen you have to put
down a ten thousand dollar down payment
and we keep half and I was like what oh
why if you like damage anything in the
building I guess so but so I think
probably not Renovations but I think
decorating for sure and was the reason
that you wanted to buy mostly like a
financial decision like you thought it
would probably be smart to build equity
in a place in New York yeah that
definitely is my main reason sometimes
I'm like wait why am I doing this again
I'm like it's just
like actually just like have something
that's like a good asset to have
um but definitely I also just really
like New York I see myself staying here
for a long time so I'm like okay it
makes sense to me that like I have a
place
um and also I think it's fun for Content
as well to be like new apartment
decorating people love the mentors
honestly if you've moved every year
those videos just do so well people do
that they do yeah all the time so
painful but it is good for Content yes
just keep doing that
uh does the gulp have an HOA or how does
that work yes it does
um very high HOA can I ask what it is
minus 2600. whoa but I get 60 of it back
wouldn't be Reserves
I really have no idea but very high HOA
but then they said oh no you actually
get like annually you get 60 of all the
HOA that you paid back and I'm like why
do I just pay like 40 and like not do
that but my guess is that they need a
certain amount of reserves by the end of
every year and then if they don't use it
they give it back to you but there might
be a repair that they need the money
that's my only guess but I'm not for
like an assessment maybe I'm not sure
but maybe I don't know we don't really
do co-ops in California or Vegas but
it's way more common here because the
price of real estate is just so high
yeah speaking of HOA they raised the HOA
in uh my community mine got raised too
are you serious yeah I don't know what's
happening mine was raised I think it was
like almost 100 a month
raised no increase are you gonna send
them a letter you know why part of me
thinks this would be a great video and
I'm really part of me is worried about
it and part of me thinks it'd be a great
video
going over their budget and reacting to
it I would love that I think that's
hilarious you explain like HOAs and
everything and then I was told the car
the car they Patrol the area in which is
probably the building or no it's not a
building it's like a gated community
okay okay so there are probably my guess
is maybe like 500 homes
I don't know but they had this car that
just like goes around constantly with
little lights on the back it looks like
a Ford Focus or something like this it's
like a Google I'm told someone reviewed
the documents
guess how much that car is per year to
lease they're paying this every single
year it's a fourth Focus
I'm gonna say I'm going to say some
egregious number fifteen thousand twenty
thousand to lease the Ford Focus yeah
what do you think it's a Ford Focus so
this is probably a thirty thousand
dollar car yeah maybe maybe the car
Market's High maybe thirty five thousand
dollars to buy the car outright just to
lease it like not even like including
the person driving it or anything no
just delete the car itself
I mean now I feel like I should say like
20 000 just to say something crazy you
wanna hear crazy yeah forty thousand
dollars a year that is the cost of this
car do they have multiple they have a
Lamborghini what I think very well could
at that price actually forty thousand
dollars a year that's a good question if
they have multiple I don't I only see
one of them at a time maybe they have
two but still even two we're talking
realistically uh 500 a month per car so
it should be let's say you have three of
them fifteen eighteen thousand dollars a
year for three of them but then you okay
insurance right gas and stuff like that
25 something 40 000.
I don't get it the surveillance in my
neighborhood is 200 000 from my
neighborhood per year but your
neighborhood is my neighborhood's big
but this is huge it's a big neighborhood
but still I was thinking I was looking
at that and I was looking at my my HOA
docs and they're like pulling in like
seven figures a year I would love to I
would love to review it and but I do I
realize HOAs like if you on the bad side
of that you're like oh log listed you
like they will make your life awful and
so it's like do you really want to go up
for what like you get a funny video out
of it and people are like oh look at
that point forty thousand dollar car
is it worth it I don't know because all
of a sudden then they're like hey Graham
here's a notice your car is too loud uh
and you have to remove it from our
premises because it definitely
just wage war against the HOA I don't
want to move that's the thing then it's
like because
they would have the right as the HOA
they they supersede me you know I could
complain but like at the end of the day
they have the final say do you bite the
hand that feeds probably not
but still 40 Grand crazy uh yeah I think
it would be great if I get on that HOA
and just like cut and cost like how much
like the car
we have lucky Lopez get us like a 5 000
card this guy he literally was planning
on attending an HOA board meeting to
complain about that's funny what was it
the weights in the gym the weights in
the gym that of the community he's in
okay so the weights end at 50 pounds and
I thought they should end at 70. and I
thought it'd be a great use of capital
if we could just increase the weights at
the gym that would be fine oh my gosh
and I was even gonna plan out like that
like the residents would live longer
with the higher weights and therefore
they'd be able to make more money
so I thought it was a good investment in
the future that's a great and more
people would want to move there if
because they have that because they have
not only more higher weights but also
because the residents were in better
shape that's genius and they had bigger
muscles so they'd entice more people
right it's like marketing it's great
marketing yeah 70 pound dumbbells yeah
it also strong residences like yeah
everyone looks like liver King is
walking around yeah
it's a backpack
this is everyone's just carrying the
barbells like up and down the street
that's smart man it was that's a really
good idea pitch it to him yeah I think
so I like it but yeah they came out with
this Rule now where you can't park on
the street after 10 p.m oh
so all the cars have to be fit so here's
the thing they said their preference was
that all cars be parked in the garage so
you can't even like park in the driveway
in the garage unless the garage is
inaccessible
um or like unusable for whatever reason
and then you could park it in the
driveway but like the goal is to get all
cars out of sight after 10 pm wow that
is very specific yeah I mean interesting
what's the point of a driveway you know
and then they also limited the size of
the car that you could have parked in
front of your house yeah so they they
wanted to prevent people from having
like the big Vans or like you know
little buses or stuff like that parked
in their driveway which I was never
bothered by I don't know I was bothered
by it but they said the Aesthetics are
off we have problems yeah there's a
height requirement on that and there is
actually they did enact a decibel sound
for your car's exhaust
uh what HOA are you living in men this
is crazy I'm being serious though they
honestly a decimal requirement for the
car yeah but are they actually gonna
accost somebody who's like driving their
car the thing is the thing is no but
they re they create a system where they
could do anything they want to they
could find something so if they don't
like you they could say well you drive
that car and it's a little bit too loud
and we're gonna go we'll enforce it on
you but the other guy he's cool but we
don't have to do that but we'll do it on
you wow so they create an environment
where you have to play by their roles so
that's why I'm like do I really want to
go up against it and like yeah probably
not but it would make a great video
true they're gonna be like we are gonna
increase Graham's fee exactly 100 and
only him
I don't know it's it's for me it's just
the cost
if we could figure out where we're
wasting money and bring it back down
because then I worry this was an issue
with Los Angeles is that there were not
HOAs but city services and things like
this that would be taxpayer funded but
then the money would go to somebody
who's like running the company who's
friends with the person who set it up
like I'll give you an example there was
a a homeless shelter in Los Angeles
and I think the rent was like 60 to 80
000 a month someone investigated this
and it turned out the person who owns
the homeless shelter that they're
leasing for like 80 grand a month was
friends with someone on the city board
and the rent was twice market value and
they never actually set it up so they're
spending twice the market value it's
worth 40 Grand he's getting 80. and it's
empty and it was never used as a
homeless shelter and if there's there's
a lot of stuff so like what if someone
on the HOA board is friends with the
person who's leasing the car for forty
thousand I'm like this is probably maybe
conflict that's a good point right there
I don't know I should investigate I
don't know where it's going
yeah that would be like a coffee Zilla
Style video where like you had the flu
versus your own HOA that no that's what
that is is like an idubbz type video new
style idubbz video I like it I don't
want to move I don't want to move I like
I like where I'm at I'm just I'm just
curious you know that's all I'm just
curious join the HOA
become one of them
imagine for the start raising on Jeremy
imagine imagine for the video that like
I joined the HOA to influence that would
be so good dude
so down in the grass
I love that video idea that was like
ridiculous Frozen I would love that idea
no because everyone has to vote on them
so you can never get anything ridiculous
I'm just curious about some of the
contracts this is not to scare you out
of your apartment
that you're buying with HOA yes I'm sure
you're going to be just clutter I know
what I'm getting into it's okay they
don't need patrols they don't need that
luckily let's talk about I ask uh every
guest this yes if your income is made of
a pie yes okay how are the slices
looking like if we're to assign a
percentage on each slice where is it
coming from I don't know why I use the
pie analogy but it's just what I do say
pizza if it's a pizza what are the
slices well no because the pizza that
the slice is supposed to be even pie you
cut your own slice you can be a Big
Slice small slice so oh that's yeah true
oh so how's that I'm gonna be like this
is 76.13 exactly yeah well I'm actually
probably say
um 25 AdSense
and 75 brand deals that is what I would
say so if the majority
um like brand sponsorships for sure just
because like it's like AdSense right is
like it's okay but like it's not
super good
um
also I mean just as like a vlogger
channel I mean I think like my like RPM
like CPM is like pretty decent but
there's definitely other genres out
there that are probably better
um
but yeah I'm working on like merch and
matcha like I said so hopefully those
will become slices of the pie but for
now it's really just like AdSense Brands
so looking to diversify for sure yeah
and is increasing the income one of the
like a primary goal of yours right now
or is it mostly just to continue to
build sustainably and then potentially
dip into other things it's definitely
goal is always just to
building that Community there but I do
think it is like always like a
interesting bonus to be like holy crap
like your income can grow with that
um and definitely just for also safety
reasons I do want to dip into other
things just because I feel like I do
have faith that YouTube will last a long
time but at the end of the day like you
never know so I think it'd be really
cool to like have a brand that could
potentially
um even like start as my brand something
like matcha I feel like I could start
similar to like merch like use some of
my own I guess like star power in a way
to kind of kick start the business uh
but I do think it's also a business that
I could have
um that is just a business that maybe
people buy from and don't even know who
I am down the line do you have the
infrastructure set up for that like do
you already have like it planned out
like everything kind of ready to roll
out or is this an idea that now that
you're working on it's something that
I'm in the process of so we're
definitely trying to still figure out
like Logistics and things like that but
I've gotten to the point where like I've
tried to Source some different matchas
um figuring out like what people's like
roles are gonna be who I'm gonna work
with and things like that so it's still
it's still getting there but I want to
launch it by this year though for sure
yeah I've noticed with bankroll coffee
the coffee itself doesn't have a lot of
margin but the accessories do like if
you were to sell really okay cool it
might be different from matcha yeah but
coffee beans are expensive and there's
like a price point where people don't
want to pay above like 12 to 14 for like
a bag of premium coffee yeah so that
kind of caps it out but straws are great
um cups are fantastic if you have like a
branded cup
um oh gosh we have ice cube trays which
do really well I don't know if that
would work for Macho I mean I think all
those things would probably work
similarly Cub I know people will even
like like tote bag frother for matcha
actually something as well
um they're definitely little things like
that yeah would be cool but that helps
and those are little cool upsells so
like for our coffee will it kind of
break even on the coffee but then at
checkout hey if you want to deal on this
and throw this in it's like that will
kind of make up for it yeah definitely
looking into matcha like because
I'm just like I know I want to do like
ceremonial grade like make sure it's
like really good or like top of the line
from Japan all these different things
and matcha ends up being so expensive
for just like the tiniest little bit so
even if you buy like a little tin like
probably like the market rate is like
I see people sell for like 24 for like a
little tin but it does last like forever
I think it'd be amazing if you actually
went to Japan yeah and like made a whole
thing on this um that would be cool that
is the goal uh what was the one that the
Breaking Bad missed call
oh like Dosa yeah yeah they had a really
cool story where they like went to
Mexico and it shows them like going
through and like meeting people and
figuring out like the culture and the
history behind it and like whoa that I
think if you applied that to yeah and
like going to Japan trying it out like
learning who makes it like like who's
behind it and like really the art and
the graph and the history behind it like
yeah and you find some like a story
behind a really cool supplier there or
like someone who makes it out of passion
is really in it it's like you know 20
Generations in it's like just doing this
one thing I don't know
it's like a tea ceremony yeah
special then it's not just like hey I
got a matcha this is cool because I like
it but there's like this cool history
behind it and people are going to be
curious like why is that one the best
yeah and you can be the best exactly so
yeah no it's definitely I've never been
to Asia like ever in my life so I would
love to like go to like Korea or Japan
um especially Japan to look at matcha
and everything so it would be right I
would do that I think if you're gonna do
it I'd say do that and find like a good
supplier yeah yeah it'd be cool
definitely language barrier will be hard
but I will figure it out that could be
part of the video too yeah yeah I'll get
a translator that's cool is there
anything you want to discuss yes wait
Graham I actually have a surprise for
you we have to close your eyes are you
serious yeah I am serious I love
surprises I know you're gonna love this
surprise you have to close your eyes
though actually yeah and you have to
hold out one of your hands oh gosh is it
is it money
yes you're gonna put money in my hand
yes all right
okay keep them closed all right
yeah there's nothing really that'll like
spook me unless it's something like
crazy oh it's not that crazy all right
okay keep holding it all right okay
maybe like lift your hand a little bit
what is this
why are you laughing Jack dude you're
gonna love it keep your eyes closed but
can I see this hand
okay oh close
okay no you can open
yeah trying to guess what it is
you like it it's more
you get it
that's funny
were you prepared for this yes I was it
was in my tote bag actually like you
thought of this like in advance yes I
did before I came down here I I was
gonna do in the beginning and I forgot
and halfway through I was like oh I need
to do this still oh man it's been a long
time since I had one of these but yeah
all right
[Music]
no
no that's so jeez all right wow yeah oh
keep going give it a chance yeah he
really likes it uh-oh you dropped some
yeah who's that who's the housemate or
that this is Luke's room Luke shout out
to you Luke thank you for letting us use
your room very gracious of you we really
appreciate it you went on Colin and
Samir yes I did tell me about how that
was that was really fun
um I had probably met them like maybe a
year prior
um they're just really cool guys super
chill and it was really cool to be on
the podcast I felt like so honored I
feel so honored to be on your guys we're
honored to have you yeah yes I've
actually seen quite a few of her videos
I meant to tell you what's your favorite
what was my favorite
I used to watch so many of like just
like I really when I was living Upstate
I was like I'm gonna have an investment
property so I literally would be like
watching every video that's like about
like having a property and like what you
should do and I never ended up buying up
there and of course I buy here where the
Market's like wild but that's okay thank
you that's so cool no oh my gosh I'm
trying to think about any questions I'm
just glad that
got the graham cracker
thing down well now you can now you can
clip that Josh too wow that's what it
means holy miracle I did not get it no
are you serious okay duh wait what did
you think it was I just thought it was a
s'more are you serious even I got that I
was like oh it's more like maybe like
Graham wants some more because he's
that's even I recognize that I got it
like immediately that's why I was like
biting my hands
so that you could get it I've had a very
long day we've been recording you know I
feel like this New York Trip's been
draining you gotta excuse me for that
Jack is it easy too I literally I
literally thought I could sleep in every
morning jokes because he's you know he
wants some more of something
money I don't know views
put that in there
like Jack's little bit at uh I don't
know if you would get this thing do you
know Infinity Edge Falls oh my God like
as an inside joke though no it's not
inside yeah I do know what it okay you
know the infinity edge has an edge that
goes down into like a little Jack saw a
pool like that he's like dude the pool
has a little mini pool or something
what did you say like what is why why
does it have like a second level yeah
why is there another level to the pool
like we gotta show that that's funny
dude the pool
I was like that's the Overflow for the
the pool how I know man now I know
graham cracker graham cracker that's why
you're putting your hand over yes
exactly so it's like uh dude you're
funny that's good that's a great joke
congratulations thank you thanks so much
uh of course did you get a free stock at
public.com did you guys check out all
the links Down Below in the description
your links let me Down Below in the
description thank you so much coffee
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
cool thank you guys thank you yay that
was great